foreign
this shipment of giant turbine blades is
part of a wind farm project being
constructed on the Shetland Islands
a tiny archipelago more than 100 miles
north of Scotland in the UK
its Builders say the farm will be the
country's most productive onshore wind
farm when it's finished in 2024. yet
this remote community in the North Sea
roughly half the size of Rhode Island is
also surrounded by some of Western
Europe's largest offshore oil fields
the flow of oil money over the past 50
years has brought jobs and prosperity to
the people there but that flow could
soon be more of a trickle here's what's
at stake as the islands overhaul their
economy from relying on fossil fuels to
clean energy and how that plays into a
broader energy transition taking place
beyond this small corner of the North
Sea
the North Sea around Britain is running
dry
after about 45 billion barrels of oil
have been produced here over the last 50
years roughly 6 billion barrels are left
according to the North Sea transition
Authority an industry regulator that is
not even enough to fuel the United
States for one year
near Shetland oil rigs are being
scrapped but the islands have an
abundance of another energy source wind
so a shift is underway
the Shetland Islands are one of the
windiest places in the UK so windy in
fact that turbines at the four wind
farms currently on Shetland must be
stopped at certain times of the day to
prevent the local grid from being
overloaded shetland's got a really
strong wind resource where it sits in
the very tip of Scotland it's got very
very strong winds that there means
you're getting high energy from your
wind farms it's also got a lot of
infrastructure that's been catered to
oil and gas and a lot of expertise more
windmills are on the way along with a
connection to the National electricity
grid that could enable all households in
Shetland plus half a million UK homes to
be powered by wind as soon as
construction of the Viking energy Wind
Farm is completed according to the
company behind the project this shift
though is not without challenges for
Shetland both onshore and offshore local
Fishers are worried about turbines and
undersea cables disrupting fishing
Waters around Shetland a big Warden
offer area and and windmills and it's
unfishable to us so it's basically taken
away our
livelihood it's like Cynthia farmer
right I'm going to take half your field
and fence off you can't you can't put
your sheep or cows there you can't use
it offshore Wind Farm developers have
said that there is ongoing engagement
with the islands so there's two key
challenges at the offshore wind industry
is facing today and that is ramping up
to meet government targets that are set
in place for Net Zero it takes roughly
you know five years from to build your
project to get through permitting stages
and actually bring that project online
so if you're wanting to meet that 2030
Target you need to be planning these
projects no and then also cost
challenges where we're looking at
inflation and the increasing cost of
capital expenditure keeping one hand on
the oil drill then can seem quite
appealing and amid protests by climate
activists in July Britain committed to
granting hundreds of new licenses for
oil and gas extraction
but it's great to be in Scotland to
strengthen our energy security with more
licenses for the North Sea but also
speed us on our way to Net Zero with
carbon capture and Storage it's no
secret that the the margins are lower in
offshore wind than they are in oil and
gas and that does pose a problem for
these kind of rural communities that are
very reliant on established oil and gas
hubs but worldwide winds are changing
the US aims to have 30 gigawatts of wind
power installed in Seas by the end of
the decade and after power roughly all
of Texas
in Europe the number of offshore
turbines is set to increase by nearly
400 over the same period
the Shetland Islands are well placed to
help meet that growing demand but as a
broader energy transition gears up and
seeds become more crowded the next
challenge will be for new and old
Industries to find a way to coexist
foreign
[Music]